[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we're here
at the rooftop of the dream hotel in
Hollywood and it's a pretty dreamy
little day here we're catching up with
the ladies of bachelor nation at soul
society's Fall collection launch that
includes a former bachelorette Jojo
Fletcher how much has your relationship
changed since working out so much so
much I look back and our relationship
has grown into something so much
stronger and more beautiful than I think
we even expected to happen and it's just
awesome like we we get each other
our relationship is I'm really happy I
love hearing that no I know it's just
because I think right after you go
through hard times and it's not easy to
transition into normal life that quickly
and we had a hard time you all go
through these these situations where
you're like trying to figure it out
you're able to get through it it turns
into something very beautiful I know for
Jordan and I it was really important for
us to kind of take those cells away and
be together and be at home and just live
in our moment I'm really happy with my
life right now do you feel pressure to
keep people updated to like post on
social media you know I think in the
beginning you feel that way but I think
Morgan and I way that we don't anymore
I'm really bad at keeping up on my
snapchat intern story but I really am
trying to learn when to disconnect and
to live in your moment
to just enjoy people accompany when
you're with them I know you get I think
when I also also like sometimes feel bad
about doing this as a reporter because
what we have to ask you guys the fans
want to know is what about the wedding
is gonna happen
oh no and if I didn't talk about though
well I mean right after we got engaged
we were like we're gonna get married and
we were like talking about in there like
whoa okay let's live life so we really
took this last year to defuse each other
and live live and get into some normalcy
so it hasn't been like a topic of like
conversation and we never felt pressured
but just like last month we were driving
in the car and it kind of popped into my
head I was like maybe we should start
thinking about it now so I'm kind of
getting the wedding bug a bit that's the
same time in size some of them was just
gonna rush in so I think Jordan has said
in a recent interview he wasn't sure if
you guys would go to televised wedding
ring I know cuz we both talked about it
and that is such an intimate day I think
for both of us that you dream about your
whole life and you know we don't know
how a televised wedding would look if
that meant that we wouldn't get to have
that day exactly how we would want it
then we wouldn't do it on TV because I
would never want to jeopardize that day
for anything you and Jordan are doing so
great he's working on you know hosting
and covering sports what is next for you
I'm still doing my real-estate stuff so
I'm actually the tail end of flipping my
house back in Dallas I'm having a lot of
fun kind of doing a lot of seven of
fashion and beauty space I'm working on
a couple campaigns right now that it
revealed just yet but I'm really excited
for so I'm just doing a lot of things
that I love